let's get to your top five takeaways
from yesterday the cardinals arizona
unbeaten they have been so dominant this
season i wouldn't watch that game and
i'm going it's it makes sense why
they've been this dominant they have
players everywhere that offense is
loaded it gives me flashes back to what
you used to think watching kansas city
play the last few years there is so much
talent on that offense kyler is just he
almost can't even get touched back there
he's like wow
and kingsbury is doing some really
creative things as well and defensively
isaiah simmons j.j watt chandler jones a
great secondary buddha baker had a pick
they are one complete team that's your
take how good is arizona right now
rodney this is wild man
hey man it's a trip watching him on tape
because you see all these defensive guys
chasing kyla murray around and they get
so frustrated because they think they
have him and all of a sudden he'll dip
and he'll you know hit outside and he's
throwing the ball down the field but for
me i'm really impressed with just their
unselfishness as an offense you know you
think about rondale moore you think
about christian kirk aj green these guys
aren't complaining um deandre hopkins
about how many catches it's all about
winning the football game and that's
what you have to have when you have so
many weapons and also think about
just the running back james connor he
looks like a totally different person
chase edmonds out of the backfield i
just love this offense they got they got
so many weapons and from a defensive
standpoint you talked about how loaded
they are and you see guys like jj watt
who's a veteran player chandler jones
hustling getting to the ball when they
had that um goal line stand when they
stop trey from getting in the end zone
it's just that type of hustle that type
of effort that's really getting this
team to the next level man and i can see
why they're undefeated jack
and and it looks like jj watt rod like
that it doesn't look like some halfway
version of jj watt or an old version or
a hurt version
i mean he's bullying guys on the field
mike mcglinchey's having a really a good
year and this is probably a year about
four or five for him so it's where you'd
expect to be seeing his best football it
didn't matter who they put on him he was
having a serious serious issue is j.j
watt big time issue chandler jones big
time issue he's just getting driven
backwards and you think about for san
francisco
that's a matchup that they have to find
a way to win i mean if they're going to
win football games in the west in the
nfc west they have to figure out a way
to block those guys and i just don't see
it and trey lance there's that ugly
interception that he threw early in the
game to boot a baker now they're going
to try to punch one in
fourth and one at the goal line bam get
smacked right at the goal line i just
thought all game long you're going how
much more advanced right now are the
cardinals than their san francisco and i
think in large part it's because all
those pieces they brought in simmons and
the defensive front j.j watt is such a
huge ad if he stays healthy this feels
like a super bowl built team to me in
arizona
the key for j.j watt is he doesn't have
to be the three-time mvp defensive mvp
because he's no longer that purse that
player but he's got other guys that he
can depend on and that's the beauty
about being a veteran player going to
another team that has other players you
don't have to be the main guy you could
just kind of do your job and expect that
your other guys are going to do their
job and that's what you're saying from
jj and he's having a time of his life he
has an offense they can score points um
defensively he's got a a plethora of
good players around him and now what
he's doing is as a veteran player he's
speaking to these young players and he's
coaching them up and i just see nothing
but positive things coming from
the arizona cardinals especially like
you talked about if they can just
maintain that level of health
they are one talented group let's get to
another talented group the chargers over
in the afc west all these teams in the
west right now what is it about the west
coast i mean all these teams out there
la la unbelievable san francisco still
hanging on arizona darn good it's all
these west coast teams that keep getting
better and better so the chargers the
chargers have now knocked off kansas
city they come back knock off the browns
another team at the top of the afc
what are you seeing out there with that
other la team everybody talking about
the rams it's the chargers making
headlines now
well i'm going straight to the coach
brandon staley and what he's done he's
changed that mindset now he's got those
guys believing that they can win and i
love the aggressive mindset now i
thought he was crazy on a fourth down or
two at his own 25-yard line i think he
went for it they went for it on fourth
and seven he kept going for it and i'm
like this guy really trusts his
quarterback he really trusts his offense
and when you have an aggressive mindset
like that your coach your players are
really starting to believe in the
coaches saying you know what he believes
in us we can do this and it's no
hesitation fourth down they go for it i
love what brandon stanley is doing you
can see that they're having confidence
whereas years before they couldn't
finish they would have penalties special
teams mistakes they couldn't finish at
the end of the game and now he's
developing this mentality where they're
having confidence where they feel like
they can finish against anyone and it's
a beautiful sight and i'm not even
talking about the weapons and mike
williams and all the things that they
got on the offensive side of the ball
this team could really be special if
they continue to follow their leader
brandon staley
i thought that this really should have
been a game that the browns win there
was two plays that they gave it away
with this very well may be one of them
right here this is just a herbert run it
looks like but it was two mike williams
just complete blown coverage plays where
mike williams is running completely by
himself this may be one of them nope
this is just another blown coverage that
time it's keenan allen but it was the
one where herbert's running to his right
williams is running a post back the
other side and he just throws to me
there it is he's the only one on that
side of the field it's just complete
blown coverage and in the first half of
that game you had the browns feeling
like they were taking control of it and
again mike williams is 40 yards down the
field there's nobody within 20 yards of
him so this game to me i thought
cleveland looked like not only can they
hang with they should have could have
beaten the chargers in la i mean so many
times they're bringing eight guys in up
front hammering this running game chubb
had an awesome game kareem hunt had a
good game
and one other thing i'm noticing rod is
that i don't think baker mayfield trusts
obj how often was odell beckham jr open
and i mean open open and baker's
throwing into tight coverage because he
doesn't even want to go to obj that said
a lot to me about their relationship and
the trust that is non-existent
that's the thing that really stood out
to me
you know he drops back and he's looking
at donovan people's jones and i got
odell on the other side i got odell
beckham on the other side going
one-on-one and he's looking at donovan
people's jones and i'm like what is
going on kevin stefanski either um
you're using
you know odell as like a dummy or he's
not a hundred percent like what's like
you gotta go to him he's a very talented
guy and you want him to continue to
build confidence get him the ball
i'm just sitting here stunned too i'm
watching tape i'm like what's wrong with
odell why isn't baker even looking his
way
i don't know maybe that's directs
direct you know information from his
coaching don't throw it to odell
i don't know what's going on there
he's missed a ton of time right he's
missed a lot of time and they've had
success when he's not on the field right
they've really a season ago they took
off when he was not on the field like
this offense came together and started
producing at a very high level run game
got going jarvis landry got going got
involved with the tight ends all of that
happened when obj was off the field so
you just have to wonder how much that
comes back to baker and his comfort with
obj but there was at least three times
in that game where they're running a go
route and a deep cross to odell beckham
jr the safety's taken to go and odell
beckham jr is running by himself 25
yards across the field and you're going
oh it's wide open again and he's forcing
something else where and it kept
happening and i thought that stephanie
was calling the play to say hey baker
it was open the first time it was open
the second time it's open we got to
throw this ball to odell beckham jr and
he didn't do it and he also had that
fourth down drop early it was fourth and
two obj had the crossing route baker
threw it to him and he dropped it wound
up resulting in a turnover on downs i
wonder if that just played into well he
said i'm done with obj this game because
he was so open and not getting the ball
which i found fascinating
yeah and offensively you know i was
really impressed with the charges austin
eckler i mean this little dude i mean
who impresses you more than him i mean
he is so tough running in between the
tackles and i you know the guy's been
hurt a little bit but when he's on the
field he is productive he's tough he's
strong he can catch the ball out of the
backfield you can line him up as a wide
receiver you can put him in the slot he
just does everything and this is the guy
that really doesn't get enough attention
mike williams has been absolutely
fabulous for for them he's big he's
athletic he can make a lot of catches
but austin eckler makes this offense go
and i love the way justin herbert is
spreading the ball around it's just a
really good offense and i like to see i
like what the chargers are doing
on the offensive side of the ball man
and that defense will continue to get
better as the season goes along
move you along to your third headline
here rod you said you talked to tom
brady i remember you telling me this you
talked to tom brady in the off season so
what did he tell you and how is it
translating
no i mean we talked about this too and
he told me he said look this offense is
going to be ridiculous because this is
my second year in the offense i'm a lot
more comfortable and i feel like we're
going to put up a bunch of numbers and
that's exactly what he's doing at 44
years old he's throwing five touchdowns
in a single game it's just been
absolutely remarkable to see what tom is
doing and just the comfort level that he
has with antonio brown antonio brown
looks like he's 28 years old so i
he looks unbelievable mike evans is that
big fast target that they get the ball
down the field and this is something
pretty special because they don't even
have rob gronkowski yet and i've always
said if i were coaching rob gronkowski i
would let gronk sit five or six games a
year let him play maybe 10 to 12 games
play some games in the regular season
take some um plays and some games off
during the middle part
but really have him ready when the
playoffs come in the latter part of the
season so this is probably a good thing
for rob gronkowski getting that rest and
rejuvenating himself
isn't that just a crazy thing but i i
feel the same way about it that it could
be a positive for the overall season of
the bucks to lose gronk at the point
that they did and is and it's an injury
that he'll be able to come back from and
i would anticipate be able to come back
from at full gronk speed and this year
to me he's just looked like faster you
mentioned a b looking younger they must
have they must have old tb12 method just
going throughout that sir that's what
i'm seeing a b looks young i'm looking
at gronk and i'm like gronk looks like
he's 28 again like when is he fast again
he's got a little speed back to him but
i'm thinking about him missing all this
time five games in the middle of the
year if he's healthy for the playoffs
when everybody else is beat up from this
17 game schedule look out rodney
harrison look out
you'll be the biggest dummy on the
planet if you got tom brady got his plan
at 44 years old and you don't follow his
program i would say tom who's yourself
i'm gonna pay you to cook where can i
come into tb12 and do my stretches my
bandwork everything that tom brady is
doing trust me he offers this to his
teammates but a lot of times they don't
want to do it and you see antonio brown
you see gronk and you see mike evans
mike evans is staying healthy you know
antonio brown is healthy and it's a
reason because they're following tom
brady and that tb12 it really works
there you go
as always the tampa bay buccaneers are
still right there at the top of the
league when you start thinking about
who's going to go chase this los angeles
super bowl you got to have them right
there we saw how much brady loves and
relies on gronk i thought in the game
where they went back to foxborough and
he wasn't on the field you specifically
you get down around that red area when
he doesn't have gronk he always looks so
much more uncomfortable so get him back
let's get to your fourth headline aaron
rodgers and devonte adams this duo
nobody seems to be able to stop it they
have this unique communication that's
non-verbal but they have an ability to
find that back shoulder and do some
remarkable things just knowing each
other so well how do you cover these
guys how do you take devante adams away
hey man we sit here we always talk about
double teaming a wide receiver and
it's not that difficult it's just you
put you put the corner back and either
whether he plays outside technique or
inside technique whatever technique he
decides to play the safety plays
opposite of that and you just double
team the guy you play physical with him
you take him away and you force aaron
rodgers to go elsewhere but every time i
watch tape i'm getting i just i don't i
just don't see it you got you got them
both double covered and he runs straight
between the corner and the safety this
should not happen if the corner gets up
there and jams him and slows him down it
won't happen how does this happen this
is just crazy and this happens every
single week if i'm a defensive
coordinator there's no way these players
could play for me playing that type of
technique and it's coming from the
defensive coordinators you got to get up
there jam them if you're playing inside
that technique force them outside
toward the sideline and let the safety
take him now you have him taken out now
he has to go somewhere else devonte
adams is the guy when we're in san
francisco he was the guy against um
cincinnati he was the guy on the same
route a deep end that put them in
position to kick the game-winning field
goal you have to double team devonta
adams and take him out the game
and this was a game that the bengals
could not lose i just don't think they
could lose this one and if you look at
the second half of their schedule it
gets so much harder and this was a tough
game early that they could have stolen
it was at home you still have pittsburgh
west to come in there i'm just looking
at looking around the afc north
baltimore is now four and one baltimore
only has one loss pittsburgh starting to
win again they have seattle this week
who doesn't have russell wilson you
gotta anticipate they are likely to win
that game and then the cleveland browns
look awesome i mean they had there's no
way they should have lost to the
chargers but they let them come all the
way back basically using all the fourth
downs that you described to display so
aggressive and steal an extra down one
series two series three series and wound
up putting them over the top but they
needed to go win this game and if
there's one concern that i have about
cincinnati it's with joe burrow who has
been phenomenal but the turnovers are
starting to happen he's starting to
force the football and have some ugly
interceptions that are really costing
this team i understand that kicking was
the ultimate story when neither kicker
could make it at the end but how
concerning some of these interceptions
we're starting to see from joe burrow
because he really hadn't seen it so much
in his past
no it obviously is concerning but that's
something that you feel like you're
gonna deal with you know with a rookie
quarterback is those interceptions but
the thing that really bothers me is i
mean he not really bothers me but he's a
very confident kid so he feels like he
can he can put it in in all the type
spaces
that he can possibly put him in but at
the end of the day you you can't throw
interceptions you can't turn the ball
over and it's up to his head coach zach
taylor to to maybe bring him back hone
him back in a little bit and you know a
lot of times you get really antsy
because a lot of big plays to jamar
chase and higgins and and boyd but at
the end of the day you can't turn the
ball over and that's something that
every head coach every offensive
coordinator preaches to their team
yeah rod i'll get you to your fifth
takeaway uh it's we've basically hit on
the top of the afc the interesting thing
is that the afc in my opinion has gotten
a lot more fascinating with kansas city
just falling back a step or two thinking
about all the teams that are in the
picture at this point the bills
the chargers the chiefs are still
obviously in the picture the browns i
just think it turns into maybe a
five-team race at this point so the
bills handle kansas city at home and
that game really wasn't particularly
close what's been the key to this run
they've created in buffalo
it's been the head coach it's been the
head coach and i think the coach head
coach sean mcdermott he's done a great
job of giving his
assistance full power full autonomy you
look at brian dayball he was with the
patriots he's done a terrific job with
josh allen you know yes josh allen has
talent but look over the years and how
he's ascending how he's getting better
every single year he's getting better
and the poise that we saw when we're in
kansas city the comfort level in the
pocket moving around keeping his vision
down down the field emmanuel sanders has
been terrific the chemistry that they
have but just look he never panics he's
still directing traffic moving he's
moving to his right and he's throwing
that off of one foot who does that you
talk about dawson knox and the impact
that he's had five touchdowns as a tight
end he's just doing a great job man and
then on a defensive side of the ball you
think about leslie frazier and the game
plan that he came up with keeping two
safeties back at times playing man free
where they're playing man-to-man on
third down and now you have the middle
safety lurking for the protection on
travis kelsey and those those um short
crossers so i just think
sean mcdermott has really empowered his
assistants they're the this coaching
staff is really the res the the reason
why this team is playing so consistent
and playing on this level and props to
the players as well but the coaching
staff has these guys prepared
yeah there's a great point and rod the
bills didn't blitz at all so so do we
feel like that there is now a new book
being written is there a new book out
defensively saw the chargers use this
strategy saw the bucks if you go back to
the super bowl use this strategy and
beat my homes as well now we see it
again with buffalo and they beat them
handedly is the book being written about
how to stop this kansas city offense or
do you think andy reid finds some
solutions here
well i think andy reid will make
adjustments that's what great coaches do
and you can't keep doing the same thing
and that's when you're whenever you're
dealing with a great offensive mind as a
defensive coordinator you have to have
variety and that's the same thing coach
belichick did against tom brady he
played some man he played some zone he
blitzed him in directly in his face he
rushed three he's dropped eights at
times so that's what you have to do with
a lot of these quarterbacks that you're
facing you just have to show them a
variety of defenses
one one final one for me i want to hit
you on coach dave all because offensive
coordinator for the bills came right
over to us before the game and you two
had a brief conversation what were some
of the sentiments what was the message
that you were sending to him what did he
send back what was the feel you got from
that conversation
no it was it was all good he just came
over gave me a hug you know asked me how
my family was doing and i said coach
what's up man you gonna attack you're
gonna you're gonna tack these guys down
a deep part of the field he just looked
at me gave me gave me some dap and then
jogged away and was and just smiled and
winked his eye at me and i knew it i
said you know what he saw what i see on
film he sees that kansas city safeties
and their db's are very vulnerable in a
deep part of the field and that's
exactly what he did he straight up
exploited those guys and it was just i'm
like wow to see josh allen leap over
guys throw the ball down the field and
just saw how in control they were
offensively and we talked about a jack
we're not even overly impressed with
their run game like they have solid
running backs but they don't have
anybody that keeps you up at night
anybody that fears you but those are
solid players man and props to sean
mcdermott he did his thing
yeah the only guy that keeps you up at
night coming out of that backfield is
josh allen when he takes off and runs
that's the only thing that'll keep you
up at night worrying about those guys
but as soon as dave ball gave you that
wink he gave you that little wink
running away i was like man i knew i
should have picked the bills i should
have changed the pick right there
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports